non moi on était on attend on était deux
il y avait un copain qui s'appelait
philippe maitreau et j'attendais
j'attendais je savais que je l'avais
puisque vous tapez avait dit mon nom
mais j'attendais qu'ils disent mais trop
et il a dit métro et donc on était super
content reconnaître même de préparer
ensemble ces il était dans sa promo il
était dans ma promo j'écris a tellement
enfants il venait vous écrit tellement
fort que les métros de sainte cécile est
un peu la tête il y avait des orchestres
musique de chambre les ingénieristes ont
joué et le mec de dca airs étaient tous
bien
la ville a rien a certainement
l'acoustique parfaite et a privé de
bonaparte
et on le concours d'entrée c'était ici
ah non non non ça louis jouvet à y avait
pas de ces dates première première
premier tour c'était dans les petites
salles d'eau
et puis après on un jour en anjou dans
le sac dans la salle je vais vous donc à
lui devient pouëze et je sortais par là
encore en parlant de en parlant de
l'afrique en parlant de la religion et
tout ça et on voyait ça est devant il y
avait un copain qui donne à bouffer ou
pas des pigeons qui s'envolait tous
quand on ouvre à la fois
vous avez beau tout faire mais vous ne
pourrez pas exclure cette part de
l'humanité pour lequel cependant le
christ aussi cependant est mort je
disais tout ça et je fus choses sortent
et par là
c'est planifié ton truc de pigeons ouais
bah oui on la croyait à 8 c était déjà
le sens de perspectives regarde ça déjà
c'est très beau non 5e la photo ouais
non je vous ai dit rien
et puis je me souviens à un moment donné
quand j'ai pris je prend l'identité de
l'infirmière j'enlève ma perruque blonde
je fais en espagnol quand la cabello
soit les libéraux machination de l'oréal
et de quitter la maladie est la
télévision américaine
la du temps là d'un moment on m'a dit
que tu es le meilleur
madix est le même qu'un beau mais
staline cette année senior et si le
fonds n'aurait pas dû prendre un futur
où l américain non c'est le meilleur du
monde et comme vous m'avez vu le vent
soutenu par tout moyen restant je m'en
fous mais elle est très affectée
le grand critère m'étais ailleurs tous
poils et les sciences du va être apaisée
et mes grands vautours est tout ce qu'il
ya à l'intérieur des familles autour de
moi tous mes bijoux et sacs à main et
pour mon anniversaire
faisant rentrer d'autres moi je me
souviens de toi dans un beckett
ouais on a vu deux en deuxième année
avec wii avec adrien on avait joué godot
avec bruno putzulu palliser bladimir et
- estragon alors délicieux aspect riant
allons-nous attendre godot
c'est vrai tu es sur site ici ouais
kippa temps devant la tombe voie d'eau
excusez ya un seuil que sur les feuilles
jeu
très bien répond plutôt à l'arbrisseau
ça l'a énervé sorin qu'est ce que tu
veux continuer encore qu'on s'est trompé
d'endroit il est plein il a bondi fier
l'étudiant noir a expliqué pas nous
reviendrons demain pour être créatif de
sa vie jusqu'à ce qu'ils viennent je me
souviens aussi des cours de ce que tu
tentes aussi c'est vrai quoi que quand
tu quand tu prépares tu travailles une
scène tu prépares plein de trucs et
c'est rapide et des vachement vachement
anxieux enfin vachement et tu présentes
ça t il ya les gens qui regardent ya
après des fois des fois tu des fois ça
fait un succès quoi ainsi que ses deux
courses qui restent we did you quoi
parce que je t'ai rien des stars de
placer cet art déco et puis même sur une
séquence quoi tu peux travailler une
séquence même de une séquence qui n'a
rien à voir avec l'auteur mais mais
comme c'est juste une séquence courte ça
fonctionne quand même dans l'énergie et
tout le monde dit barak là c'est super
mais finalement ça n'a rien à voir comme
le godot qu'on avait présentée ici
en fait ça n'avait rien à voir avec
beckett en gros que ça passait parce que
c'était l'énergie de d'élèves
mais après quand on a retravaillé qu'on
la joue et on a on a cherché pendant
trois semaines à refaire à retrouver des
sensations à refaire ce qu'on faisait
ici et ça marchait pas et à la fin on ne
savait plus du tout on était désespérés
et on a répété le premier ministre
mais d'après des câbles sans savoir du
coup et là les choses se sont arrivés
quoi mais là ont commencé à rejoindre
beckett comme d'emiratis world is it a
pas forcément de colonne vertébrale
oui ça va travailler oui et
voilà et donc tu dépends pour le coup
vachement d'un mètre du metteur en scène
est et de ce que le metteur en scène pas
mais nous pas si les brillants ou pas or
normalement devrait on devrait quand
même avoir une colonne vertébrale et une
méthode de travail qui fait que quand tu
sors tu arrive quand même toujours
attention exact de débrouiller à toi
même si tu as un mettant en scène
insuffisant un directeur d'acteurs
insuffisant en face quoi tu avais pas
quand même franchement peur parfois
quand on présente c'est le truc c'était
un peu baissé mais je trouve que c'est
intéressant si avec les profs c'est quoi
forcément il couvrait ton esprit es tu
veux dire tu découvres est grâce à
foison avec les jeunes on avait fait
tout un travail sur la position de la
femme au xviie siècle c'est quand même
intéressant et puis avec avec un rien on
avait fait un travail sur bourdieu sur
les textes de bourdieu je peux je
n'aurais peut-être pas connu ça sans
s'en veut mais par exemple les ges c'est
une des seules qui est venu qui m'a dit
ah ça c'est une pensée juste à quoi tu
penses elle venait presque comme une
caméra là tout près tous prêts à
travailler vraiment dandin dans l'ain
team dans le team du du corps de
l'acteur jay bernardi quand il nous
faisait travailler la tragédie ou quand
il faisait le travail et la tragédie à
d'autres et que je regardais moi il y
avait j'ai gelé travailler comme ça
aussi après moi c'est à dire avec ses
discours en pro taz
discours en apothéose les acm et les
voyelles blanche à contretemps qui vont
chercher on voit ces trois jeux pas dupe
on va pas entrer des empreintes à ses
heures normatif est aujourd'hui au
conservatoire à 10 heures catherine
corsini va filmer
devinez quoi devinez qui devinez qui est
voilà et on cite nono tu vois ça je vois
là un discours en en a' poteau c'est un
discours où catherine corsini va filmer
aujourd'hui voilà deux acteurs au
conservatoire et donc tu dis tout de
suite enfin je veux dire le discours en
prothèse c'est un discours qui est tenu
et puis c'est en tragédie c'est comme ça
tu lâches rien te lâche rien te lâche
rien et puis pof à la fin c'est tu vois
c'est un discours qui est toute en
tension comme ça et et hulu le où tu
écoute parce que tu veux savoir la suite
tout est révélé à la fin puisqu'on en
apothéose les voyelles blanche à
contretemps cette aide est dévoyée des
voyelles qui sont qui sont mises
toujours à un moment charnière dans des
motions pour le personnage en tragédie
et donc si tu suis tout ça finalement tu
arrives à retrouver c'est ce que voulait
bernardi arriver à retrouver l'état dans
lequel était l'auteur quand il a écrit
son texte
ça c'était intéressant parce que en
appliquant prothèse à pau doses à
claques mais tout ça que lui il faisait
toujours des parallèles avec la musique
crescendo diminuendo pas comme ça tu
l'achetons volcan que ça c'était
intéressant parce que quand même on
arrivait parfois comprendre le texte qui
pouvait être incompréhensible à cause
d'une ponctuation ou alors massacrer à
cause une ponctuation de l'éditeur
me souviens qu'un jour j'étais adrien
n'était pas là et donc on était on sait
on s'est barré enfin mais moi j'étais
dans l'école et donc on avait on n'avait
pas cours et j'étais venu dans le
théâtre c'était là dans cette loge là où
tu es et y avait ce soir que saïd qui
donnait un cours ici et puis subitement
ils m'ont vu et ce soir ça ne m'a vu et
il a commencé à dia qui alors je dis bah
c'est moi je ne me cachais pas moi alors
je dis va c'est moi et vous venez nous
voler notre théâtre
si non non non non et après je l'a
attendu à sortir du bois là c'est moi je
m'appelle eric caracal j'étais là je
pense que je peux voler mais voilà un
bon voilà ah non ça j'adore parce qu'il
se trouve que la vie n'est fait que de
première fois les premières voies sont
les plus intéressantes et c'est ça qu'on
voudrait tous se retrouver cette espèce
d'état d'innocence quand on travaille
ouais c'est à l'état de l'enfance
et en même temps moi j'aime les acteurs
qui jouent leur vie qu'ils jouent j'aime
aussi la distanciation énormément mais
j'aime bien les acteurs comme peter
lorre quand il sent que ça ça brûle ça
vibre même si parfois le jeu est
excessive mais j'aime quelque chose de
tente et que rien de tenter
j'ai voulu être actrice au départ pour
l'amour des mots et pour pouvoir être
plusieurs personnes et ça vient du fait
que je me déguisais chez moi il y avait
une sorte de panier à déguisements et
puis on se déguiser et on devenait
quelqu'un et on prenait cette voie et
nôtres physicalité changé même des
langues dès l'enfance et j'avais une
soeur qui filmait et un jour j'étais au
test de comptes tu as avec l'accent
australien le lendemain j'étais une
fermière le lendemain jouer là l'aristo
anglaise et ma soeur film et puis moi
jouer les personnages
enfin - au nom enfin nous on a un nous
est plutôt que le premier on a
maintenant il doit on t'aura la scène
sinon amer mais tu préfères les écrans
français
oh bah oui mais j'ai pas eu l'occasion
je les fais au conservatoire je vais
jouer un peu désiré j'avais joué désiré
avec un titi parisien allait vivre le
truc way jouer la bonne en fait j'étais
quelqu'un de bain extrêmement émotif
voilà je faisais des crises de panique
d'attac panique des choses comme ça pas
donc non mais donc j'ai comme ça j'ai
déjà pour des raisons de santé comme ça
j'ai repiqué
la terminale et donc comme j'avais le
niveau je me faisais chier donc voilà
c'est fait mais c'est mon frangin qui
m'a inscrit au conservatoire normand
parce que lui voulait faire un peu de
théâtre et il m'a inscrit aussi j'avais
du temps pour faire un enfin du théâtre
n'avais pas la vocation
non je suis plus dans la vocation c'est
venu après non au début au début moi
j'étais un petit marange est un petit
comique en classe voilà le salon était
d'aider voilà on y met moins limiter les
gens jettent et les professeurs voilà
c'est venu comme ça c'était assez
potache spirituel beauté arletty était
une femme d'une grande beauté
monga note extrêmement belle et ça les a
pas empêchés de jouer la reine et la
boniche l on jouait les deux chiens
alors que j'ai l'impression surtout
aujourd'hui qu'on voit tout d'un aspect
social non socialiste ou donc forcément
socialise la beauté aussi un nom vous
est trop belle pour jouer une concierge
qu'est ce que ça veut dire bon galop
dans l'argent de ma vie' attend voilà
alors doit légalement petits poèmes
juste le dernier vol juste ça c'est
parti là la beauté ne secret elle
poursuit là elle périt la poursuit pas
elle persiste rattraper les plis dans la
prairie où le vent passe ses doigts le
dieu fera que jamais tu n'y parviendras
ça c'est très juste mais moi j'ai
l'impression que j'en ai pâti d'avoir eu
un physique fort parfois il ya des gens
qui ont des préjugés
ceux-ci voulu faire le conservatoire
pour ça pour vous dire je veux pas
arriver parce que j'ai un dos nu
physique top troc sur les portes non je
trouve ça obscène moi je venais d'un
autre monde je venais de la mode du
monde de l'image et je voulais me fondre
dans cette école je voulais absolument
être comme les autres qui avaient fait
quatre ans des théâtres ont j'ai fait
comme seulement deux ans de cours mais
mais c'était important pour moi de
d'avoir une technique
donc tu veux dire que la jalousie
pendant mon passé de mannequin
peut-être que je gênais peut-être que je
devrais oui un petit peu oui il ya une
signification engagement est-ce que je
suis un acteur engagé
c'est ça engagement dans la vie publique
pas tellement parce que je suis pas
quelqu'un de très politique - en fait
finalement enfin je suis en engagement
il est plus ou poétique qu'on va dire
mon engagement il est il est vrai quand
je joue ou quand tu réalises un film tu
raconte des choses qui sont qui font
partie de la vie donc qu'ils font et
même de la vie présente je crois que
quand tu es acteur quand tu joue un rôle
le rôle de renseigne sur ce que tu es
toi quand tu fais un film sat renseigne
sur sur ce que tu es toi finalement
finalement donc je pense que c'est
important pour un acteur d'avoir un
point de vue sur le dans le monde enfin
sur le ce sur la société sur le monde
dans lequel il vit il vit mai
et voilà et c'est suffisamment violent
d'aller sur un plateau de d'essayer de
faire un film comme le genre de film
qu'on essaie de faire qu'il soit pas
forcément du divertissement même si
c'est bien le divertissement jeudi pal
qu'on craint enfin même on essaie de
dire un peu autre chose que des c'est
toujours assez violent finalement donc
l'engagement il est là dedans non dans
le choix de textes que tu fais quand tu
dis donc moi je décide
deux de jouer bond ont proposé d'autres
choses dans des théâtres privés etc
j'ai dit non
je suis allé travailler bond à la
colline voilà l'engagement il est là je
trouve que nous finalement ce qu'on
essaie de montrer quand on quand on fait
des films et où il y avait par exemple
les certaines personnes peuvent vous
peuvent peuvent voir mon fils me dire
c'est triste ou ne pas avoir envie de le
voir pour ça c'est de la limonade mon
film à côté de ce qui se dit ce qu'on
voit à la télé si tu si si tu regarde
pas ça comme une image qui défilent
devant toi si tu si tu prends un peu
conscience de citer un point de vue un
peu politique quand même
eh bien
atta
oka
il fait la gueule 1
allez viens on va manger
j'aime quoi
j'ai passé loin les zones richard il y
avait un panneau à vendre
ok les revenus
je sais pas
je veux pas le savoir
elle est bien
ah oui elles montrent ce c'est moi qui
doit dire gg déprécie une pascal
catherine breillat elles montrent ce que
ressentent les femmes
je connais moins bien c'est normal
christine pascal
mais pour breillat ça a été important
pour moi parce que c'était mon manifeste
politique à moi enfin à faire un atelier
de l'enfer je suis pas allé comme allez
tiens une question pour je suis pas allé
comme ça gratuitement comme si c'était
comme il s'agissait de n'importe quel
film je me suis impliqué dedans sachant
que comme on vit une époque extrêmement
la rétine c'est vachement répressive je
savais que ça pouvait réveiller et
provoqué presque des sensations des
sortes de critiques incendiaires et
lapidaire et de la part de la société
parce que le film parle de ça justement
de 2,2 ce qui est de vraiment obscène
qu'est ce qui est obscène qu'est ce qui
est est ce que les oreilles d'une femme
ce sont dans le domaine de l'obscénité
oui dans certaines religions qui a parlé
de de toutes ces questionnements est-ce
qu'on peut être la maman et la [__] en
même temps moi c'est mon rêve je pense
qu'il ya un avant et un après breillat
pour moi je crois qu'elle m'a fait
absolument prendre conscience de qui
j'étais parce qu'elle m'a elle m'a
réellement révélé à moi même par le
regard que live sur ma personne dans le
off avant que le tournage commence oui
mais aussi comme une parole elle oui
mais
je crois qu elle l a dessiné et comprit
très bien qui c'était avant que je ne
commence donc il y avait une sorte de
pacte de confiance même si je la
connaissais que très peu mais il ya eu
une sorte de de liaison et de connexions
très fort sur ceux qui nous touchait
toutes les deux je me souviens en marché
à staline sur le canal saint-martin et
on parlait de viridiana de toutes les
deux espèces de choc que ça a été pour
nous ceci
voilà c'est ça citation philippe
clévenot
quand je joue je n'ai pas vraiment peur
je me mets en état de peur je veux
pouvoir me dire qu'est ce que je vais
dire après pourquoi ça continue et si je
ne disais plus rien là en plein milieu
de la représentation
voilà non mais ces sources affirment
jouer dans cet état là je trouve ça
incroyable de se dire à chaque moment
pourquoi je m'arrêterai pas là si je
m'arrête là se mettre en danger comme ça
ça c'est ça c'est être en tous les cas
pour moi on n'ose mots avec le moment
présent
quand on parle de depardieu la monstre
sacré et c'est assez vrai depardieu je
trouve que c'est une de ses ses forces
c'est ce à quoi c'est d'être dans le
moment présent
absolument quoi
d'ailleurs tu sens bien un acteur qui
ont commencé à dire action enfin qui se
bloquent qui se tuent c'est qui qui
serait j-10 fille quoi dès que tu dis
actions qu'il s'agit des filles puissent
elles il ya un truc qui devient
important et il ya déjà une petite mort
dans le côté rigide et érige rigide
ça m'a toujours frappé ça au cinéma tu
joues et tu croises le regard d'un d'un
technicien tout de suite ebay selon ria
c'est assez drôle quoi mais mais mais
mais toi tu n'as tu n'as pas faire comme
si tu les voyait pas tu es là tu joues
il ya un caméra cayla mais derrière il
ya des regards si tu tombe dessus il
faut le prendre et c'est et tulle
incorpore à ce que tu viennes qu'est-ce
que tu es en train de jouer c'est ça
peut être très beau faut pas nier ce à
quoi moment présent est important il
faut faire avec
caramanlis
oh
regardez corse a libéré
d'arbaud
la réalisatrice avec qui j'ai travaillé
juste avant me suis carrément liste et
on vous doit du pognon enfin on va vous
le filet engouement encore quand tu
passes permet j'aimerais faire un tour
tu dis à ton compte oui d'accord
1 il va il a été c'est bien très bien
alex a laissé suffisamment commun parce
que c'est le bâti il est gauche comme ça
oui c'est ça quand je les mettais un
normale celle là juste là où ça sortait
un centimètre c'est ça alors répliqué
dans le bâti de voix pour un essai est
riche et avec les chars avaient barré
les vieilles charnière comme un appel
des trucs un peu vu infliger temps là
crémone généralement les travaux c'est
comme ça ouais ouais je vais pas pour sa
façon bravo quand même 25 qui vivait
alors tu l'as pas oui j'avais quinté je
l'étais mais un peu trop je les ai fait
un peu trop brun tant pis pas grave je
crois qu'il était par la baguette et a
dû cesser bêtement et chez moi c'est
pareil on va tout repose là-dessus
et le reste c'est gâcher quoi c'est dû
la du plâtre avec du bois qui
remplissent les trouver tu as beau
métier en fait c'est le seul vrai métier
parce que quand tu es acteur était au
bout du monde
qu'est ce que tu veux dire je suis
acteur tu parle pas la langue les mecs
ils t'envoient alors que si tu es ma son
bâton mur tout le monde est plus grave
c'est quoi cette église
c'est une église protestante regardez le
chantier incroyable non
tu vois regarde ça ce vieux bâtiment là
tu rachètes tout ça et tu t'es ça c'est
des bureaux le soir tu mènes une grande
tente un vide qui tu veux tu peux faire
du bruit et tout ça me regarde
et ça devient d'où cette passion pour le
bricolage enfin même plus que ça parce
que mon père voilà parce que mon père il
est bien le bâtiment et donc il m'a
passé ça je peux pas marcher dans la rue
sans regarder un immeuble en misant
retiens ça c'est à vendre de la petite
maison je vous ai montré pour moi ça a
toujours été liée au chantier
c'est marrant parce que j'habite dans un
endroit là où il ya un chantier juste en
face des chantiers en construction
serait toujours été un truc qui m'a
poursuivi qui doit être aussi peut-être
qu'il y ait au père je pense
alors j'avais une question sur les
paires on n'a pas arrêté par les toits
avec des pertes et père spirituel
ouais alors papa chéreau et papa du
perron tu te sens fils tu te sens fils
bah ouais je crois que j'aimerais dire
non mais oui oui un jeu un jour il
faudra il faudra que je passe perd un
peu ça sera bien
je me sens prêt non
tiens regarde ce bâtiment tu laves
répondu ça doit être une structure bois
pareil tu vois qui tient tout le truc
c'est vrai dans un décor ouais ouais
c'est un la lumière était très bien de
ce genre là je vais vous montrer
quant à fait les repérages de ton film
tu as fait beaucoup de photos oui j'ai
fait beaucoup de photos je veux montrer
voilà ça c'était tout ça c'est les plans
du film un peu si j'arrive à bien
photographier un endroit je sais que mon
décor c'est un bon décor et que j'aurai
aucun souci à faire bouger les acteurs
dedans j'ai déjà quelque chose où je
sais pas tu vois ça ces chutes du
niagara qu'on avait mis dans mon film
voilà ça par exemple je les cadres est
comme ça sent le ciel dans le film parce
que parce que comme c'était l'histoire
de deux frères il y avait une mer assez
agité une autre très calme
séparés comme ça alors pour moi c'est
raconter ça je le sais pas obligé de le
déceler mais tu vois c'est voilà c'est
comme ça ça c'est un acte voilà mon
acteur vincent rottiers julie julie et
vincent quand tu diriges les acteurs de
la musique dans la tête déjà dessous
disons que c'est lié certainement oui
une sorte de rythme on voit bien des
acteurs qui vont pas bah voilà deux
acteurs incroyables
d'ailleurs c'est ces deux acteurs la
scène même des acteurs du sud pour moi
je me sens très à l'aise en espagne
parce que mes parents sont espagnols ou
même plein en ce moment chez en algérie
je trouve les gens du enfin j'ai pas il
ya un accueil à une chaleur humaine et
que j'adore et je n'y avais pas du tout
pensé mais quand ces deux là se sont vus
sur le plateau ils ont commencé à faire
parler en arabe
ouais ça j'avais l'impression de voir
deux frères en fait le frère aîné le
petit frère il y avait il ya quelque
chose d'une d'un lien de parenté entre
les deux maurice bénichou égard elle il
ya des gens qui ont l'air toujours
d'adolescent quand même quand tu
travailles avait avec maurice garrel
saisir il rejoint tout à fait dès le
jeune acteur avec qui je travaillais
avec vincent rottiers quand il voit un
enfant il ne le trahit pas parce qu'ils
pensent que c'est un homme avant avant
de penser que c'est un enfant donc il
pense qu'il peut tout à fait apprendre
des choses d'un enfant
une tête incroyable
ça se trouve ça super beau parce que
l'écho
et ça au passage de l'un à l'autre c'est
bon aussi mais je trouve que l'écho du
passage de maurice où il apprend la mort
du frère l'écho on l'a juste dans le
prend dans le plan d'après on à l'acteur
qui fait rien quand tu vois il
pleurniche pas quand on lui apprend à
oui moi j'ai très peur de la mort la
décomposition que ça vienne vite la
dépendance puis on de peur de perdre
peut être utile peur de ne plus pouvoir
exercer mon métier
parce que c'est aussi un métier qui
existe avec la dépendance c'est un
métier qui s'est fait avoir cette bonne
femme à côté de moi si si si si si et
puis même comme si je fais du théâtre je
me fais je suis j'ai peur à l'intérieur
et puis je vis avec ça mais après
la peur de pas être regardé ça aussi
c'est de travailler mais ne pas être
regardé ça c'est quelque chose qui me
fait peur alors il ya je pense comme moi
je suis aussi actrice parce que c'est
pour défier la mort c'est pour devenir
immortel pour faire un pas que
à la mort donc forcément je préfère être
immortel dans des choses qui vont un peu
direct cinéma c'est filmé la mort au
travail
voilà j'ai toujours le souvenir de de
lino ventura dans cinéma cinéma on lui
disait mais alors jeune génération vous
fait pas tourner pourquoi il dit ça
passe je sais pas il était super triste
et la journaliste eut dit vous pensez
pas que c'est parce que vous fait peur
hein pour jean lui dis ma famille mais
je vous fais peur et elle fait ou est un
peu et il était d'une grande tristesse
par rapport à ça c'était pas un moins en
moins bons actes en fait à la fin de sa
carrière au contraire mais le désir des
gens c'était un peu arrêté a été moindre
par rapport à lui et je trouve ça
insupportable de vivre ça donc donc tu
as quand même envie de gagner son
autonomie pour te dire ben voila si un
jour le désir des gens s'arrêtent jeu il
ya quand même une une possibilité de le
continuer à exister dans ce que je fais
dans un an voilà c'est important medhat
a choisi de mettre en scène de mettre en
scène au cinéma au théâtre
oui ouais bah c'est venu par la photo
ouais voilà
ouais c'est venu c'est venu par la photo
mais c'est venu aussi d'abord pour ça
pour trouver un endroit en marche dans
lequel tu puisse fonctionner et ne ne
pas être amené à toi nouveau en tant
qu'acteur enfin tu vois c'est vrai que
c'est d'un moment sortir un peu de 2 200
arrêts faire l'acteur sans arrêt se
mettre de côté quoi pour laisser le
personnage arrive et laisser l'auteur
s'exprime et les 10 et le metteur en
scène montrait ses idées à 6 et parfois
c'est impeut voilà c'est bien d'avoir
moi j'adore faire ça mais c'est bien
d'avoir des endroits comme ça un peu en
jachère ou tu puisse aller et
et montrer un peu ton univers aussi
attend cct que là c'est compliqué pour
l'impression d'être dans le film dans
ces quads à ce précurseur de brèches et
celui des petits sketchs car valentin il
ya un sketch qui s'appelle chez
photographe savard qu'une femme me
marier très très très grand il a cette
fois c'est jean rousset un lien il venir
gens n'arrivent pas les retenir fut de
loin car elle sous x et puis ça marche
pas mais tu vois ça c'est beau ça avec
des traces de balles et des traces
voilà
j'aime bien avec le petit chapeau
chinois et ça c'est super beau parce que
c'est du bus et du pôle à quoi tu vois
nicolas sur la qualité c'est magnifique
c'est extraordinaire avec ton appareil
et puis voilà ce qu'on peut dire je suis
un collectionneur
non parce que je m'en suis servi de tous
ses appareils soit avec le les cas soit
avec ça monti ce que vous avez vu tout à
l'heure c'est mon le petit un petit
canon ixus ouais c'est un petit outil
numérique 84 millions de pixels voilà ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui permet
de faire des photos qui sont comme un
carnet de bord pour moi et qui permet de
de déblayer le terrain et ensuite je
pense qu'il faut enfin moi moi si tu
veux je vais vous montrer j'ai fait un
sujet en tunisie j'ai pris que cet
appareil mais c'est mon fétiche et mon
réflexe voilà c'est les premières photos
donc c'était du noir et blanc
maintenant je fais presque plus de noir
et blanc.c'était aux états unis il ya un
truc dans les premières photos qui est
comme un premier j'ai quoi de sa ses
instincts et demi j'ai photographié
d'avoir des paysages que tu verras après
mais après je me suis assez vite je me
suis mis à photographier les gens et à
ne pas avoir peur d'y aller c'est
quelqu'un qui dort mais il ya beaucoup
de gens qui dorment aussi
voilà un sans logis dans le métro
finalement ce surtout quand tu as le
rapport aux films ou quoi
une photo c'est une image arrêté presque
des parfois des images volées
je trouve que le cinéma est plus dure et
en même temps c'est plus passionnant
qu'est ce que c'est tu essayé de filmer
des gens de faire en sorte qu'ils soient
bien début c'est pas très bien puis tu
bredouille un peu puis ensuite élu tu
finis par trouver enfin je trouve ça
bien parce que tu t'attardes avec des
gens alors qu'en photo bon we have et un
maquillage incroyable qui dort beaucoup
ça ça c'était à berlin ont répété avec
aux stores mail elle là c'était notre
salle de répétition il y avait ce
mannequin sous les gradins
je l'avais sorti parce qu'il ya un petit
bonhomme qui avec un hôtel juste à côté
avec un petit bonhomme qui était la
dessiner voilà sa sage aimait bien parce
que c'était un los angeles et s'était
malibu beach c'est là où il tourne
alerte à malibu si la plage qui est là
mais il ya là on est au mois de novembre
il y avait le pen l'océan pacifique
était comme ça que tu es très beau avec
cette porte comme ça ouverte me faisait
penser du beckett porte qui ouvre sur
une chaussée qui est défoncé sur rien on
était à sfax et dans l'hôtel dans l'aide
dans laquelle nous étions il y avait un
soir les élections de miss fax donc
voilà elles sont là elles sont les
trouvera en dernier voilà elles étaient
toutes dans l'hôtel c'était assez beau
parce qu'il y avait des grands mères les
petites filles ça c'est en tunisie
ça pique
ça c'était des maisons troglodytes
cinéma au cinéma rex
une route
qui
lors des duels
famille
au mas qui tu es
est où
dans ce pays
sylla
m
entretien
tout seul
m
c'est ce photographe qui a suivi
vivienne lit pendant quarante ans de
carrière de quand elle était mannequin
au début à sa naissance dans l'actrice
dans un coma crise au théâtre anglais
dans les films de korda jusqu'à ses
années hollywoodienne et puis le retour
dans les années 50 avec brooke avec
laurence olivier
ll y aller à fond dans les rôles 1 et
voilà
qu'est-ce qu'elle s'abandonner ça c'est
dans ce qui suit quand même déjà comment
ça s'appelle en est pas moins voilà
voilà voilà un très bon et très bon
oui c'est pas mal ça hein voilà mais si
je trouve c'est mieux c'est mieux de
rentrer dans la photo donc voilà ça
c'est vraiment un travail sur la couleur
et c est ça qui pourrait s'appeler
couvre-feu catherine oui il ya bien pas
beaucoup de l'humain finalement là
dedans ça c'est la gare de liverpool
c'est un travail sur les humains sont
tout petits comme ici c'est un travail
vraiment sur la couleur
ce qui une copie à ce que les termes
voilà c'est au japon mais il faut avoir
le vivre là où c'est ça ça monte monte
de coupe coupe le truc ce qui était
intéressant c'est ça c'était comme une
forme d'anagramme vivre à kirin les gens
se confondent finalement avec les
bâtiments non voilà les deux tours
séparation balcon ça c'est au japon
comme il ya des tremblements de terre il
n'enterre pas les lignes électriques
c'est aussi je vous montre ça c'est un
voile assez pour essayer de de fer
d'égayer un peu tout ce à quoi la photo
c'est à dire qu'au bout d'un moment il
ya des périodes mais faire du quelque
chose de très naturaliste comme ça
prendra une photo très net et c'est pour
moi de moins en moins intéressant donc
c'est essayer de te voir essayer de de
trouver une matière qui est peut-être
plus proche du dessin ou et donc pour en
arriver à cette photo que j'aime
beaucoup et qui a été fait en numérique
et qui ressemble presque à une peinture
là qu'on joue plus on est et on a une
conscience qui est grande de dire quand
tu joues quand tu joues des grands
textes quand tu joues arthaud quand tu
joues beckett ont entre joe jaunay quand
tu joue edward bond quand tu joues
tchekhov
tu vis de plus en plus difficilement
puisque tu as toutes ces consciences
quand même que tu peux pas oublier quand
même parce que quand tu joues sa secte
après tu passe du temps avec eux mêmes
avec ses auteurs n'a donc il ya une
conscience avec laquelle tu vis après tu
peux pas oublier sa main
comme ça donc je pense que tu vis avec
ça et que c'est pas c'est en même temps
c'est assez gai pas ce que c'est
j'ai l'impression que tu t'ouvres de
plus en plus il ya de plus en plus
intelligents il ya de plus en plus de
conscience qui qui qui qui se bousculent
en soi et en même temps c'est il faut il
faut il faut savoir les porter mais avec
il faut de la légèreté choix de
l'impression
là que les relations
le chantier du béton
chantier en face de chez toi
c'est juste en face de chez moi
la taxe en tout le monde faire du cinéma
parce que tu as croisé serpent de mer
à 36 ans à thé vous
tu peut allumer un petit peu dans
l'appartement à l'humain le allogènes
tout doucement pas trop fort voilà vas-y
à la gêne
tout doucement voilà voilà
le reste avait dit
qu'est ce que c'est
donc
et puis la petite
la petite qui est là
corsini bien
e attends je crois que pour monter un
étage en plus j'adorais ses portes
patois
bon
oh
en
non
mais quand que tu étais ici
est ce que on te disait parce que nous
on n'a jamais été dans les mêmes classes
finalement on a peut-être eu parfois les
mêmes professeurs mais est ce que tu as
vu quand même quelqu'un qui t'a déjà dit
par exemple à quoi tu penses c'est quoi
ton objectif
ou est-ce que tu travaillais aussi en
terme d'action tu sais les actions
stanislavski yen n'ont pas vraiment non
programmeurs n'ont pas vraiment enfin
n'y avait pas ce que j'avais des noeuds
est ce que quand il joue et tu avais des
noeuds d'acteurs est ce que tu arrives à
des moments charnières où tu adhères
blocage et est-ce que tu sentais que on
venait et puis on pouvait défaire le 2
août et des arrivées oui à des résultats
mais oui mais c'est bien souvent je sais
pas j'ai l'impression que c'est bien
souvent moi qui ai fait le travail pour
défaire le noeud je crois après mais un
metteur en scène en france au théâtre il
a sa vision de la pièce est une vision
générale il ya des très bons metteurs en
scène ou le effectivement le travail de
l'acteur est pas forcément primordial
j'ai l'impression ici je crois que c'est
vrai la trêve à ce même au cinéma je
trouve que souvent on a peut-être toit
et moi a eu deux fois trois fois 2 je
sais que breillat gakli foutrait twh
héros c'est des gens qui vont vraiment
chercher au delà de la proposition
première de la première prise ils vont
travailler avec toile dans les prises
qui vont même parlé sur la prise non
mais voilà ça rares sont les gens qui
partent finalement qui partent de
l'acteur pour développer la situation
et voilà moi ce que je repère finalement
c'est qu'un mettant en scène qui fait
une sorte de mise en scène on apprécie
cette mise en scène
si après il fait un autre un autre
univers totalement différent
les gens vont pas aimer parce qu'ils
vont pas reconnaître et je crois qu'en
france on aime bien reconnaître
du coup on mettait en scène peut monter
une pièce reproduire cette forme à
chaque fois même s'il change d'auteur et
c'est un acteur ça ne doit pas jouer un
auteur
beckett doit pas y joue pas pareil que
je n'ai pas ce qu'il ya un autre rythme
ce dont on a déjà parlé mais un metteur
en scène c'est pareil un metteur en
scène peut pas monter kafka comme ils
montent comme comme ils montent tchekhov
or bien souvent je retrouve la forme
voilà et on oublie absolument qu au
milieu il ya l'acteur et moi des
metteurs en scène comme ça j'en ai
rencontré pleins ou finalement c'est
l'acteur qui va toi tu vas tous les
soirs joué quarante fois le même
spectacle le metteur en scène il est
plus là il est déjà en train de préparer
un autre spectacle
et puis voilà il s'en lave les mains on
a écrit un bon papier sur son truc et
tout va très bien mais il ya l'acteur
qu'elle a tous les soirs et qui joue
tous les soirs et qui lui se confronte à
la respiration d'un texte à la
respiration d'un auteur à qui est là et
qui défend le truc et que ça bien
souvent on l'oubli tu vois on oublie
donc donc moi j'adore quand un médecin
un acteur finalement décide de faire une
mise en scène je vous ça beau parce que
lui au moins il n'oubliera pas ce que
c'est qu'un acteur il n'oubliera pas
l'acteur et je pense que en finale je
pense que si tu si tu fais confiance aux
acteurs au travail d'acteur et que
l'acteur lui même va définir la mise en
scène faut que ça le disent il faut que
ça travaille focalise autour faut qu'ils
aient un metteur en scène qui taquinent
nourrice qui t'apporte des choses qui te
je crois qu'au final
au début tu tues bredouille tu
bredouille tu bredouille et puis à la
fin quand même tu as quelque chose de
l'essence de l'auteur qui arrive à
sortir de tout ça